-Guys, it is time for
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
-We do this thing every week
where I send out a hashtag
and we ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
This week I sent out the hashtag
#LastMinuteCostumeIdeas,
and I asked you guys
to post some funny
Halloween costumes you could put
together at the last minute.
This is to
help all of us out.
If you haven't
picked out a costume,
I got one for you right here.
Within minutes, it was
a trending topic in the U.S.,
so thank you for
playing along with us.
And now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
last minute costume ideas
from you guys.
Here we go.
This first one is from
Nazeemo620.
They say,
"Wear a Lakers jersey
plus carry a burger equals
Shake Shaq."
This one's from
RyanBartholomee.
He says,
"If you have boxing
gloves and Hawaiian shirt,
you can become Hawaiian Punch."
Not bad.
So this one's easy.
This one's from
WellItzDaBigSho.
They say, "Carry a soccer ball
and dress like a slob.
Go as Lionel Messy."
-That's funny.
-Yeah. Come on.
This one is from
ImWalkinOvaHear.
He says, "Write 3.14159265358
on an orange shirt
equals pumpkin pi."
Fantastic.
-Come on. Come on.
It's a thinker.
-These are all doable.
-Come on.
-Yeah, I might need a little.
Yeah, a little --
What's it called?
A drum roll? No.
A drum riff?
-Rim shot.
Yeah, I might need a little
rim shot after all these.
Pretty good.
Alright, here we go.
This one's from AaronMCooley.
He says, "Put your Samsung phone
inside a fanny pack and bam,
you're a
Guardian of the Galaxy."
[ Rim shot ]
This one is from WhoU-Kiddin.
They say, "Lab coat
plus hot dog in beer mug
equals Dr. Frank-in-stein."
[ Rim shot ]
This one is from StremelUSN.
He says, "I printed a sign
that said 'I love ceilings'
and taped it to my shirt.
At the Halloween party,
I told everyone
I'm a ceiling fan."
[ Rim shot ]
This one's from SpiritualHatGuy.
-Oh, I love him.
-He says, "Wear
a Memphis Grizzlies jersey
and cover your nose
in baby powder
equals Cocaine Bear."
[ Rim shot ]
-Wow.
-This last one here
is from CH10EO.
She says, "Get a white shirt
and write,
"Error 404: Costume not found.'"
There you have it.
That's a good one.
Those are
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to
TonightShow.com/hashtags.